looking for the person who shot and
critically injured a man near chinatown
this happened early this morning near
spring mountain and wynn road hector
mejia live at the scene right now with
the latest on the investigation hector
good afternoon
hey there right now no word about any
arrests and so far metro police have not
announced any description for a possible
suspect the scene right behind us is
clear but it's right there where metro
police spent several hours scouring for
potential evidence
thursday morning wind road and nearby
streets shut down north of spring
mountain road layers of crime tape
blocked off the area where metro police
say they found a 37-year-old man with a
critical gunshot wound he's at the
hospital they made the discovery after
someone dialed 911 around 4 45 a.m to
report the shooting within that crime
scene a pair of shoes were visible in
the middle of the road as police
searched for potential evidence
employees at nearby businesses including
bank of america had to turn around until
they got the all clear
so the bank of america behind us is back
open and also talked with other
businesses they expressed concern that
the shooting happened so close if you
know anything you are asked to call
crime stoppers and remember you can
remain anonymous reporting on spring
mountain and wind road hector mejia live
local now